o amigo seu sul não sabe eu não vejo
este boneco lá no dia em que acho
perfeitamente o lado pessoal de quem
falou neto
eu os trato de que um vídeo muito
assustador é o seguinte hoje pudesse ver
coisas paranormais locais conhecidos do
demônio coisas do m
eu até tenho uma revista com escrito nem
viu ou ouviu falar do tipo é mas que é
do brasil esta pista os grandes crimes
no campo e pressionou o vasco foi lá eu
queria que o veneno liga pra eu fazer
uma compilação pequena de vídeos que eu
encontrasse o neto por ela assistir
pessoal
agora falando sério este lixo o episódio
porque normalmente envolve crianças
mortas coisas violentas portanto
preparem só que estiverem instruir se
elas tiverem menos de 16 anos não vai
ter um espírito que isto é só para
maiores de 12 anos
[ __ ] se faz mais gols ontem uma criança
já o [ __ ] um bispo com ela no pan
toma assim de próteses a música marca os
pneus do meu eu inverto em círculos e
contrário só sejam porteirinha música o
vídeo já é dada de puebla
estão no meu nome aí eu não consigo ver
isto eu só tomo sugar a alma não não
avancei isso avance e escandalizou olha
a cara dela parece estar a morrer à fome
o uk um bebê e meu deus
olho alguém está a chorar aqui
ana está muito medo aqui um boneco com
máscara rodar e tal e não sabe o que é
que esta porcaria é de vocês não sabem
são violadores são pedófilos um ladrão é
uma criança a brincar num jardim tudo
normal
é um sonho estranho funk a soma de
coimbra a brincar
nada demais eu aposto que o senhor tá
aqui filmagem tabela está a música tá
andando sempre utilizada é a pistola e
hipnótica do filme para itu sp
estou eu a segunda feira a domingo o
posto vai parecer que une o tal fantasma
vôo
como assim não é possível ea estou eu a
segunda feira já está a tentar outra vez
eu porque quero manter essa música
sempre o contrário não saber ou muito
milo bicho do demônio não está muito
bizarro mas eu acho que não é do tipo é
vista ético shift filme só assim eu
sempre fazem compilação e pois mantém a
preto e branco com uma música bosta não
o que é isto terá esperar em pé é até o
que é um povo humano com nosso patas nas
patas tom perry não tem nos braços com
cinco dedicada braço ou seja dar cinco
vezes os novos simples não acertou a
estes jovens não e depois não jogue este
ela bateu a cabeça do caraças já o
parecer um vídeo da lei que é pivô
cometeu um erro mas isso não é real e
não é real eo que não é
ela parece bater com a cabeça de chapa
olha este aqui é verdade parece ser esta
uma câmera talentos avaí parece dar o
meu voto em uma mulher a comer qualquer
coisa
ei ali chalé já possui qualquer coisa na
câmera sai taxa muito próxima de um
lento e tem cara de bruxa ou bruxo
aprisionava ok ela voltou a ser deitada
tudo tranquilo será que ela foi trancada
além da cetip pô pedra pedra eu tenho
alimentação para mais dois dias e não há
água então ela foi presa línguas tem uma
câmera faca
olha tem mais qualquer coisa que espera
aí precisa passar o vídeo alguma pessoa
que vai gente na internet convenhamos
carioca então elas a mesma empresa né
alguém chuck mas com uma câmera de
segurança ou a faixa deve ser daquelas o
extremista de cueca live stream tipo é
paranormais
alguém tá bom para poder encarar seus
conduz a urina para a porta e já está a
dar arrepio fim [ __ ] aí a faixa a
faixa a faixa ó ó para o vídeo expresse
que os filmes que vocês querem ver
imagem por gente corta um beijo no
próximo disco pop pop
hum agora é só coisas estranhas né
lá estamos a andar num sei o que é isto
é muito bizarro
só temos um corredor não é muito
discutido nem dá pra perceber o que é
que estamos num hospital ou sentam se
percebe que é a bb que uma tv
foi por tudo isto uma travesti mato
mesmo tipo é botar foto e um frango amba
[ __ ]
apesar disso não olha aí para com esses
empregos empregos aqui nessa compilação
2 pessoal quando convoquei que progride
espero que vocês tenham gostado de gama
inês comentários quais são os vídeos
pois achar um que são reais e se
quiserem mãe problema no mais feliz
depois frios estilo eu quero muito
assistir mas tem que servir as nec aqui
porque os barcos e é isso que eu passo
lá que tu brito fica a ideia está pronto